good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast I am here with a very
special co-host Aileen Cooperman from
betches hi thank you for joining me be
co-hosted together get more so this
isn't completely unchartered territory
nohe are so excited to have you thank
you for having me I was so excited when
you texted me to come on we've gotten so
many requests from toasters because
there was a lot of days of summer that I
need guest co-hosts and so many people
wanted to hear from the girls from
vetches so we're so excited to have you
we're gonna get to all the toaster
questions okay later in the show but
yeah we your wealth of knowledge popular
pop culture knowledge I'm getting older
I'm like out of touch sometimes but I
feel like as I get older I have to just
make it a point more I stay in touch yes
whereas before like I feel like when you
get older you just stop kind of caring
about like what everyone is doing you're
just like what are my friends doing or
my family and then like sometimes like
what are the girls I stopped gonna have
to doing right but like it's it's less
like so obsessive celebs but now I have
people do thank you and now the toast
does it for you so it must be now as a
host of the toast I'm very in tune
because we have to go through the news
every day but I imagine as a toaster you
just feel informed that's what I French
say at least yes they're good friends so
maybe I don't know
anyways per usually of a great show for
you today the Fast Five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast I love
that yeah I heard it I i watched
yesterday I was like wow and then you
did it right yeah let's go back to our
shark tank pitch which is going viral
and I have confirmation that it has been
sent to Robert Herjavec so Robert if
you're watching today just know that
you're my favorite shark that's even if
you don't give us a deal like I'll still
love you I feel like I've learned a lot
from shark tank I know everything I know
I know from shark tank right like every
everything that they say like how is
this you know different from all other
things like right everybody stands you
know what makes this a company not a
product right and they invest in people
not products typically I feel like well
I I also I'm the one hand shark TVs
great for like new businesses and really
getting capital and like getting off the
ground but on the other hand it's a
great platform for brands that don't
even that don't really need an ideal but
need
and for sure would you guys ever go on
Shark Tank betches I'm like for
publicity like that's gonna yeah make
for an interesting pitch case it would
be it would be fun I don't know if like
I want to let the world in on our like
business model right away you don't want
to open up the book I don't like I'm not
sure but I think it could be funny
like I feel like it could be funny maybe
we should go together no totally like
they're just like such new-age business
just like I feel like the Sharks would
be really impressed yeah I think so too
so are they watching do you think like
Mark Cuban it's very possible
I definitely we're on Roberts radar and
I wouldn't be surprised if we're on
track I really like Robert like he said
he seems actually a nice dad no he's my
favorite shark he's oh he's the only one
who's like just nice to the people who
come in he's like not he's like he's a
friendly shark he's like the one you can
swim with very like some of the other
sharks like they make they really go
below the belt like when they have
people and it's like I hate that I
really hate that it makes me
uncomfortable mr. wonderful is so mean I
feel like he's not mean in real life I
feel like that's his dagger Sona
Barbara Corcoran came on the show ends
and that's what she said yes said he's
like a big teddy bear and that's his
like show person yeah like he's all
business but then when he gets off he's
like olive oil and wine olive oil and
wine with the zip caps would you really
just like saving women or men possibly
around the world at sporting events I'd
whatsis he bought something on Shark
Tank that's like a portable wine cup
that's now but they say like every
station right I remember seeing and it's
a game-changer right yeah because I
don't want beer
no and I don't want hard alcohol I used
to I use in but now like I can just have
a glass of wine right yes a classy glass
of wine out of a plastic cup for sure
they have it one at Jack Brown man on
Sunday and I used to Chardonnay and it
was the nastiest thing I ever drank
really yeah yeah you've got to go
Ramona's Pinot
I don't understand people I don't
understand Chardonnay specifically
agreed it's never ever good and
sometimes it's the only wine choice like
we need to shift and like I feel like
everyone can agree on Pinot Grigio I
also saw of Blanc
I mean that's my favorite everywhere
have you but have you tried
moani's P no no have you no I but I like
where is honestly I'm sure it's good I
think it's sold at like Costco okay it's
just a big deal yes but I'm sure it's a
good idea to me the Pinot Grigio that I
didn't that I hated um yeah I don't know
I love someone I don't really love white
wine I don't sorry I totally agree it's
so acidic it's so weird and honestly as
someone who doesn't like red wine it
tastes too much like red wine to me okay
I love red wine though okay it tastes so
much like white wine I feel like it's
just so acidic and like people just
drink it to Instagram it and then they
like just talking about Kasota
like on snapchat like I want to like it
so badly and I'm really yeah yeah yeah
whispering angels probably like the best
one mmm yeah I have to be like drunk to
drink whispering yeah but then I tried I
had a glass the other night knows like
this is nasty right no so guys yeah that
you're saying that because I thought I
was like a little truth about Rosie I
thought it was alone like what's uncover
right because everyone's like Rosie all
day no no Rose a no day okay without
further ado the fast I stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast lucky
for you and lucky for us it was a slow
news day so like there's not much that
you don't know but Eva Longoria
officially introduced her baby boy to
the world meet Santiago and Rica best
own so and Eva Longoria did the cover of
Ally USA and she looks so cute her and
her baby it's so okay so I looked it up
she's 43 which is like so amazing to
have like your first Keo and it makes me
feel like okay all these women who were
like so obsessed with having kids like
oh I'm I'm 35 I'm pushing it like you
can wait like you can for sure but I
feel like she wanted to be a mom for
like a really long time
and I feel like now she finally has a
life like she's wanted for so long and
it's even sweeter yeah my friends and my
friends are watching re watching
Desperate Housewives and like can't stop
talking about it as if it's on
but now I've watched Desperate
Housewives three years ago and I still
can't stop talking yeah it's just so
funny I'm like that like you're telling
me as if like this drama is occurring in
2018 but like no it ended in 2012 so
it's such a relevant show it's amazing
and I got when people are like watch I
binge watching like Desperate Housewives
yes it's first of all even if you
watched it
and the day which I did there are so
many plots that you actually forget
about so you feel are being surprised
the writing is so good the everyone is
beautiful and it's so fun it's so funny
like breeze like comments are so funny
also like breeze MVP well I also like
Gabriela but breeze so underrated and
like she tries so hard and I write like
Gabrielle like kids are like just
absolutely you mean Demi Lovato's sister
Juanita Solis no is Demi Lovato's
half-sister wait I think I knew that but
then like I forgot it and then I just
like renew it again the best thing ever
that's crazy I had no idea well but like
it's so funny because my friend is I'm
like what are you up to in desperate
houses then her first time one of them's
first time like she's like well a plane
just crashed and what I'm like Carlos
it's gonna go I don't want to spoil want
to spoil a show that ended like ten
years right thanks it's not good for
Carlos right the only one I couldn't
really get behind his Felicity Huffman I
can't even remember her character she
hated her husband she was like a Tom
yeah he wasn't LuAnn it was it was Lee
Anne no no is like we blew something
between LuAnn and Lee Han yeah that's so
funny but ya know her life was a little
too real and like a little too anxiety
inducing like yeah I want to watch just
from a closer oh yeah I just I had even
when he like got cool like then he did
like yeah not good the worst very sad
stuff but not sad for eva longoria
finally living out her Desperate
Housewives dream less than two months
after welcoming her first child into the
world the Hollywood actress and activist
decided to introduce her son on the
cover of Ola USA's latest issue here he
is Santiago and reek a bass Joan is
waving hello at the world couldn't wait
to share this picture with you all the
proud mom shared on Instagram so the kid
is like waving in the picture and it's
really really cute what's the kid's name
Santiago Santiago and reek a so so cute
that article was really funny cuz like
yes that's news but then like Victoria
Beckham comments x-x-x
so lovely like breaking news I feel like
Yvonne where he has great friends memory
when she was married to that basketball
player who was like yeah a good guy yeah
and he like cheated on her
she found like all these text messages
and then like he also broke up some
other marriage and like they got
together I didn't realize that side but
I was like a lot too young to be like
knowing about somebody affairs right all
I knew is that he did gabrielle solis
dirty and that was filming well I looked
it up before like I checked her wiki
that's how I knew she's 43 otherwise I
would not have known her age I would've
been like she's like you know 35 like I
don't but ya know she's I feel like
she's kind of like ageless she is she's
she's funny
she's stunning and she's just I feel
like she just has this like youthful
vibe to her like she's just you know
keeping it young yeah she's Eva she's
either um I love her speaking of people
that I love
the next story rihanna makes history on
the cover of British Vogue September
issue so we have the photos for you she
loves good insane like the best ever
pour it up for Rihanna's latest coup
she's the first black woman to ever snag
the cover of British Vogue all-important
September issue photographed by Nick
Knight and stabbed by the magazine's
editor-in-chief Edward NFL the cover
features Rihanna dressed in hot pink
product tulle neon orange gloves and an
elaborate floral headpiece by Makoto
azuma Marlene Dietrich asked skinny
brows in a deep dark black berry colored
lip courtesy of the stars own Fendi
Beauty range round out the look I mean
I'm so so good she looks so good I want
this color lip and now that I know that
it's plenty beauty like that show me the
cover yeah so good like even with the
eyebrows like that's so so bold you
remember when people actually had
eyebrows like totally and you know what
she's doing like so much of the Lord's
work for people like me who don't really
have eyebrows either you have eyebrows
the eyebrows like in front of you but in
pictures they don't and people make so
much fun of me and it's like there's
nothing I can do other than paint on an
eyebrow and look insane yeah so it looks
good looking from the eyebrows community
Thank You Rihanna for your work yeah but
like it's so funny because that used to
be a trend like the the really skinny
like people would just make it white and
like shave their eyebrows grandma yeah
grandma which is so funny because I saw
on Instagram like Bella Hadid has like a
French manicure and I'm like is that
gonna be a thing again
like I go to the nail place and like so
many thing a French pedicure and I'm
like okay it's a big
difference between a French madam care
and a French pedicure yeah I'm Pro
French manicure honestly yeah it's an
always classy look it depends on the
color pink that you go with yes it has
to be a very light pink not like we do
limousine limousine ballet slipper yes
yes madam
those are all winners and like I
couldn't see myself like wearing a
French manicure my wedding day made my
hands feel like elegant but I think it's
like the first like it chips in a day
and then you're like that's trash
yeah when my nails chip I picked them
all off like just one like I see one and
it's gonna end
no I did this myself because I just got
a manicure like three days ago and I
picked it already off oh my goodness you
need to get like something that you
can't I can't good Joe off it's it's
like comes from like this I don't know
anxiety I understand that I can't but
also like if it's imperfect like there's
one chip see ya
oh then got it Bobby you should get like
or like the powder which I did once and
was god-awful is that like the SNS yeah
it was bad I think I might have just
gotten a bad one
okay you know yes somebody told me about
that stuff and I'm like just like give
me the regular and I also don't think
that manicures need to last forever like
I'm down I can commit to getting a
manicure once a week I can't commit to a
color for that well right and that makes
it like fun if I got gel all the time I
would always have boring colors cuz I'm
not gonna torture myself with blue but
gel also like makes it all crappy
underneath oh yeah then you're finished
yeah - like you're finished she's strong
like built have a gel manicure
when I have done amateur afterwards my
nails are brittle yeah I've started
doing um collagen peptides and now
taking these nature bounty because
taking collagen yeah okay coffee every
actually I stopped for a while I don't
know you know if it does anything well
my hair really has been growing strong
my nails are breaking less than they
were before interesting so it's doing
something okay
we had um so I'm a co-host for our
podcast diet starts tomorrow
we had dr. Murad he like does all the
skincare and he we asked him about like
what's the deal with collagen what's the
deal with peptides and he like goes on
and on basically he's he says sometimes
it works sometimes it doesn't
but like you could be putting College on
her face like there's different ways of
taking it but I
I'm like I don't know about supplements
that's interesting
no I'm like I got to a point where I was
used to take no supplements no vitamins
no collagen no nothing
yeah I'm like I just felt like a week so
I started like I just felt weak and so I
started getting vitamins I started
getting like putting okay lights in my
water and doing collagen peptides and
you know I still felt like [ __ ] but at
least mentally I felt like I was trying
right okay I don't know I like sometimes
people say like vitamins don't even do
anything to you like it's all it's like
you're taking a placebo no for sure yeah
but sometimes I just needed a placebo to
feel like I'm doing something for my and
just know like I'm okay that's fair you
know yeah you're okay anyways this is
really the story about Rihanna is really
interesting to me because the
editor-in-chief of British Vogue is
clearly in tune with what's necessary
yeah
putting Rihanna on the cover in this
amazing look and rumors are swirling
that Anna Wintour is out I read those
yeah so who do you think could take her
place cuz I'm kind of vying for this guy
like he's gonna come to the u.s. just
like in Devil Wears Prada write that
anytime I see any like anything about
bogan like Devil Wears Prada no and it's
like a true story completely they like
portray those exact people right and
only an editor-in-chief of another vote
could become the editor-in-chief of
American vote correct right I mean I are
gonna promote someone I think it would
really make sense I mean yeah actually I
don't know he's a man though so like
maybe to you like we're not gonna go
that way right because of like we need
that vitamins from Devil Wears Prada
right Italian editor I really like how
progressive this is and like how amazing
it is and and I she looked really really
really badass badass cool current I'm so
here for it because I feel like so much
of fashion these days is like missing
the mark ya know and nothing is fresh
yeah do you follow that account um diet
product I do I started following and I
feel like I know everything about the
history of fashion Fame right I'm like
wow what is this world like I never
really knew anything about fashion like
my mom was always working my dad like
dressed me like a tomboy like I didn't
like know anything and so like I'm
slowly learning I've never
like a fashion influence I like check
out my jeans swipers yeah like I bought
them like one day I got your soul cycle
just like so I'm like yeah I need jeans
but like I said I'm not like a fashion
faux or type of a person so like that
account like makes me I like to see like
how she calls that when people copy
other people she I think so is it
anonymous or like I just don't know no I
think it's a she oh I was thought it was
I mean I could be totally right no I I
mean I haven't been following with for
that long so that's so interesting but I
think from insta stories it's a girl cuz
I think when she was at Fashion Week I
think she showed her like oh I don't
think this is the thing I don't know
well anyways know the account like
really is very education s I agree yeah
it also goes to show a lot of like
fashion currently is like derivative of
or you know pulling on like vintage
inspiration which I'm which is cool yeah
but they say can't be everything like we
need new ideas you guys like I think yet
like every 30 years it just comes back
like with every like full generation or
a person going from like kid to like
have a kid there's like a new yeah it
just comes back yeah like which is cool
cuz then like you don't have to throw
away all your old clothes they'll be
worth something one day yes but I can't
horde uh I I'm I'm not that I would be
if I didn't try do you know what I mean
like I just see myself slipping into
hoarder dumb living in New York City you
can't be a hoarder there's just no space
for it no absolutely like I would
stuffing like things under my bed I'm
like yeah I can wear that one day I'm
like alright like clean out my closet
but then you feel so good after you feel
so good I literally just did that
yesterday and I feel great yeah but my
fiance is like kind of a hoarder oh if
he so he makes me look good you know so
I'm like wow I need less closet space
than you like I'm so minimal that's like
that book like the untidy egg thing were
they like I don't I don't know if they
say I don't read it I don't know what
they say but they're basically it's like
don't put it like keep everything away
that doesn't bring you joy like a people
like it some people say like you clean
out something that you haven't worn in
like one year like donate it sell it
that yes I haven't worn it the season
that it's a
intended to be more than I'm not gonna
wear it ever and right if I didn't wear
it when I was like feeling skinny then
I'm not gonna wear it now that's another
thing like that's super detrimental to
people's lives is keeping something in
there that like you want to fit in to
one day right you know but like by the
time you fit into it like no on it they
won't be in style yeah you're gonna be
like no I want to go shopping this thing
is ugly rock I had one of those moments
yesterday where it's like looking at a
couple things and it's like I tried to
wear this when I was being skinny and it
didn't even look at them so it's
definitely not gonna look good now and
if I ever become skinny again I'm not
gonna like it still right yeah like it's
just it just also reminds you of like
times where you couldn't and like who
needs bad yeah negativity and you're
like no you do not right
no I very much appreciate it back
so anyways clean out your closets you
guys if you're looking to feel better
than him okay
next story is actually kind of
surprising but that Steve Harvey returns
as the 2018 Miss Universe host yes which
is crazy because in 2015 he famously
named the wrong winner during the
pageant after initially announcing Miss
Colombia Ariana ugh we Terra's our Ivalo
as the night's big winner
Harvey revealed he had made an error and
Miss Philippines Pia Alonzo wurtzbach
was in fact the winner so they're
bringing him back I feel like he's
allowed to come back because he's not
the only one who looked messed up on
live TV like the Oscars because they
messed up now it's like you know
everyone does it like I'm not so bad and
I have to be honest like no one was
really talking about Miss Universe until
he messed up like which is so sad that's
like that old adage like all press is
good press or whatever yeah but it's
true no one would have no one he would
have even known who won if it wasn't
such a big story
yeah and he's such a lovable guy that if
anyone could get away with it and be
asked back like it would be him right I
agree I personally have never watched a
beauty pageant like I used to really
like them I couldn't get on board a
tomboy I couldn't like I couldn't watch
it I just I was like what what else do
they do the world except for favorite
movies Miss Congeniality of course but
also that story is a little messed up
too right I guess she had a
you don't even like oh that's yet to
like go through a physical
transformation in order to like be here
best self right I guess in hindsight
like there's so many movies that are
casually kind of like oh sure you know
but still it's a great movie
it is Swedish uh and also I kind of
stopped watching beauty pageants after
Olivia culpo because like it couldn't
get any better than that like she's
right you love her I think we even
talked about her when we rico's my
father at least some concerns yes I love
her very much she's done like the most
with the platform so anyone else is just
like we'll be in her shadow yes I
actually did not know that she was a
beauty pageant winner and I think I said
that last time I think you remind I like
she was Miss USA oh is confusing Miss
USA she is very beautiful she was Miss
Universe - she's very beautiful and
she's obviously very smart because she's
made a career out of like a one year
thing yeah and why more than most other
people could do Vanessa Williams - going
back to Desperate Housewives going back
yeah like she's on the cover of like the
Hulu page and like she's not even in
like the show until way later yeah it's
so crazy that it's so good for her
that's just another reason why I should
all watch the test for house I yeah but
it's interesting he's coming back I feel
like what else they gonna do right and
like I think him coming back will make
more people watch it then if it was just
another Schmo host unless it was the
host in the morning toast in which case
it would be toaster strong you guys
should consider it as a toast toast
toast I feel like being a judge of a
beauty pageant well actually that's like
such a mean position to be in but like
it must be really fun you know cuz
you're always with like other like
sealless judges yeah and it seems like
you just have a good time I feel like I
would rather judge like a dancing
competition or like American Idol I feel
like that would be so much more fun
because then it could be like you
clearly have no talent or like but I
feel like with dancing it's like they're
all talented so yeah that's like you
know ruin someone's dreams who actually
is pretty good whereas like with beauty
pageants like you can really the cream
always rises yeah like I don't watch
world of dance that's the JLo one but
like I follow JLo and she like posts the
clips and this one dance like literally
made me cry and I was late I don't know
it was the combination of this Carrie
Underwood song
something under the bridge water must be
something in the water must be something
yeah I got the bridge but that's always
the water okay my living in the water
under the bridge yeah that's right right
right
it was like these ballerinas got it was
so moving
I started crying I was baby it's early
in the morning I don't know but I said
to my friends they're like like you
should watch it
I know watch it now yeah it was so good
I was like back stalking JLo because she
was posting like incredible pics of her
from her birthday yeah she looks she
looks insane is she human like I don't
understand I don't know I don't know
what other than like genetics and money
like how you can look like she doesn't
move when she sleeps that's like her big
thing and she doesn't drink at all
mm-hmm oh my god I moved so much when I
sleep last night I slept terribly
because I was flipping nothing same yeah
her whole thing is that she like pads
herself like like like from One Flew
Over the Cuckoo's whatever she pads
herself so she can't move over to the
side cuz apparently when you moved
there's so much stress in her like like
I don't want to deal with this but when
you move to your side like your neck oh
my god that's like so nurse Jaime la I
saw that on someone's Instagram and she
was like talking about sleep neck rolls
dude it's like dermatologist said
everyone swears by and I was like I
cannot worry about my name's I can't buy
your $80 neck roller yeah the roller
I like that everyone pushes I'm like
dude that's like a toy you get like when
you put 25 cents in like a machines yeah
but you know I don't maybe it works I
really will try anything I don't know
I'll try anything like as long as I can
make sense financially right so I used
to work but like an $80.00 neck roller
I'm good right we'll see we'll see how
this pans out for everyone right next
story is really a cautionary tale for
anyone in New York but there is a serial
harder on the loose in the West Village
reports page six so like this is a big
deal you guys okay West Village
residents are kicking up a stink over a
serial farter who's polluting the
neighborhood
earlier this year a local blog posted
quote it's happens right so it can't be
a coincidence
there's some guy who I believe is
playing a fart sound as he passes people
as some sort of social experiment I
think it's always the same fart
the sleuth posted every time while I was
talking to a front and we just get
interrupted by this part that leaves a
silent and staring he plays it as he
passes and he never looks back acts like
nothing happened guy is a white college
age very straight-laced looking the not
so silent but deadly dude went for a
quiet went quiet for a while but one
area insider told us on Tuesday my wife
and I were walking by Washington Square
Park and the guy passed us and just
ripped one and we both started laughing
the couple did you deduce from the blast
it could not have been human the dude
had a backpack said the source wondering
if it housed a flatulence stimulating
device the source snapped a picture of
the prankster a hipster in shades shorts
a short-sleeve button-down shirt running
shoes and a gray back
gray backpack citizens beware okay so
are terrorists a third terrorists is on
the loose and at first when I was
reading this story I was like maybe it
just sounds like he's making this sound
which like is weird sure but he's coming
out with a scent as well I don't know
that's what I couldn't really tell like
right it's stinky it's a when they say
the couple deduce of it from the blast
it could not have been human I'm
assuming they're referring to the smell
I thought they were referring to like
the noise because it was so absurdly
loud interesting well it's just the
noise and like that's just a she's a
maybe this is Sasha Baron Cohen you guys
right calling a praying because it could
be I mean I don't know when you say it
like that article title I literally
snorted like I was like this is great
this is a news day you need to get out
into the field go down to the West
Village and see what's going on yeah if
this also kind of sounds like just an
NYU student like probably conducting an
experiment for like their psychology
class and like this is gonna get them in
a cuz that's he goes probably like has
one of those like cameras on the back of
his head or like in his like fart device
backpack and like he's monitoring
people's like reactions like okay right
who cares like and I hope whatever his
thesis is like farting in public I hope
we can agree like it's just not cool
okay but not to you know TMI or this
isn't about me but what she'll was
called to when someone told TMT TMT MIT
well when like one of my friends like
back in the day told me about like the
phrase crop dusting
I like thought of it as something that
is
creative and so funny what is that what
do you mean like I've heard of it but
it's like just someone walking down the
street and like just just beating the
crops you know like just like casually
like I'm never letting it go and it's
like just visually it's so so so funny
so like this guy like he's not doing it
like so casually he's like his machine
is loud you know right but but he is
technically a crop duster he's worth
like a like a crop burster oh my god
but it's so so funny like just the
visual I couldn't lives my whole life
without ever knowing what that meant but
you know I'm glad that I did I'm so glad
I can inform you and that like now if
someone ever uses the term I'd be like
yeah no I know it yeah but anyway this
is ridiculous maybe we should go
investigate in person totally do you
ever think of doing like toast live
toast on the ground having toast on the
ground this is life yeah
note a hundred percent when when duty
calls okay nobody but yeah we might have
to go and find out for you guys what's
really we're gonna get to the bottom of
this is pressing know the the
journalists at page six aren't gonna go
down so well we have to the writing is
really funny enough it is causing us
stink hey honey this is causing a stink
okay something else that's causing a
stink chipotles free guacamole promotion
has made a lot of people pretty angry so
I guess yesterday was national avocado
day and they were giving out free guac
at Chipotle yeah but on Thursday the
chain announced that uh their app was
like down yeah that anyone who ordered a
meal through the app or online would get
free croc yeah but the app was down so
anyways long story short they're doing
another free guacamole day today
toasters so if you want some free guac
now you know like everybody was so
apparently pissed off because they've
ate like people were tweeting that they
waited their whole day to go get their
clock and like the people would in honor
like the service so sad I know also that
you're waiting a whole day at the end of
the day yes guac is extra but isn't it
like 25 cents like a one cuacamole
like one little of this I don't know I
don't know
like I've eaten it's so like if your
whole day is ruined by not having rock
like just by it I don't know like it's a
nice gesture but it's really not like at
the end of the world right guys like
make your own people are so clumsy about
guacamole and Chipotle specifically even
though cardi and I ate there once and we
tasted duty but and it was like during
the e.coli yeah like oh you went during
no it was like in between equal a
journalist's to see you get eco no like
we just tried we were like Chipotle's
all the rage and then actually like a
time where I was really into like
Mexican food salads cuz like I love
cheese salsa guac lettuce sour cream and
like that's actually not that unhealthy
yeah so we were going and we were
scarred for life yeah I just can't like
maybe they didn't give you that the
guacamole because it had a coli I just
find that Chipotle so interesting
they're people they're like at all hours
of the day and I'm like what are you
doing no and like they also sell beer
you know they're on your lunch I didn't
even know that break from work but it
was really funny that to read that you
guys should read the tweets about like
people how pissed off everyone was and
then like there there were these like
other like Mexican jeans that like that
it was like well we give free guacamole
so Chipotle can go [ __ ] itself yeah this
is what people were saying all I've been
looking forward to today was online
ordering ACK to pull eight tweets so
that I get free guac and the website
slash app is down sad face it is quite
unfortunate that the Chipotle tweets app
is so buggy today couldn't place my
lunch order for national hashtag
national avocado day for the free guac
feel sad man
I can't order online go to Chipotle and
can't get free guac in store dear
Chipotle tweets with like a gif of a
sports thing and Chipotle is like doing
damage control on Twitter responding to
everyone like that's just this is a
disaster i yes that's quite disastrous
what do you think like it'll ever end
where it's like a national random thing
day every day like I feel like
technically it is like there's national
random thing day calm then it'll tell
you what everyday is national of like do
you think people get sick of celebrate I
think it just depends on the item like
anyone with like would love an excuse to
celebrate national avocado day and like
justify yeah nationally killing white
people right but then
like natural national like mint
chocolate chip day and like I like that
but like very specific thing yes very a
few these people but I don't know it's
like it's gonna go viral I really want
to know what the most random one is like
I'm gonna be on a hunt to find that
they're such random if you go to this
website like you'll be shocked
I'm gonna go should we go yeah I can't
remember what it is and then I like good
people can comment like what they can
read yeah what your hell us what the
most random one is no I write yeah there
are so many though where do we begin
I don't like national hat day like
that's weird like I can't blow up a hat
no I'm not gonna wear a hat there's
nothing really and there's no national
day that I really celebrate actually I'm
not into it like fur even the other day
was like national lipstick day and like
no I'm not gonna like and what right and
what yeah great alike right totally so
exciting so if I can't get behind
nation' lips today there's nothing else
I feel so sure enough yeah national
morning toast day we'll get on yeah most
a minute workout and really make a
holiday for anything
okay leave me have so many questions for
you okay I'm really excited because the
toasters have very insightful questions
and excited it's gonna be Henry slash
nervous no don't be nervous rates are
all good and positive so you are one of
the founders of betches correct can you
tell us how that came to be yes so I so
I started the company with two of my
best friends like we we went to
elementary school together we've known
each other forever we went to Cornell
together we live together and we were
sort of bored one night and we wanted to
start like a Twitter account but we
wanted to make the Twitter account like
what is it Matt narcissist problems like
we generally were just like very
observational of the people around us
like all the young women who are like
very self-obsessed and it's really funny
and we were part of that this is 2011
and so but like that was too long for
Twitter so we're like screw it let's
make a blog so we made a blog we were
anonymous it was sort of like a list
things betches like and so like the
first one was talking [ __ ]
another one was birthdays and it's just
like it was very satirical and long
story short we got a book deal and
overtime we like grew and grew and
became like a media company right so
yeah that was in 2011 and so now our
third book is coming out in October
what's it called it's called
when's happy hour work hard so you can
hardly work
so the what's it about it's like it's
like a super funny career book like
mostly for women but could be for
anybody and yeah I mean like we've
written books like that were parallel to
where we were in life like the first
book we wrote is um nice it's just a
place in France how to win it basically
everything that's like when winning was
a thing you know and I mean yeah and
that was like it was like a self-help
book by girls her 22 really know nothing
like other girls yeah it was really just
funny like really just ridiculous
content the second book was on like a
dating book very like cut the [ __ ]
everything we do is like saying
everything everyone is thinking but like
right like saying out loud and yes so
now we're sort of we feel confident
enough to write a book about career and
like running a business and just and
it's not really only about running a
business it's um like how does it an
email how does that a calendar invite
you know like so many people don't know
how to send calendar and so really
annoying like this person do not know
how to write emails like now I do but
that was probably my biggest struggle
when I was like just working as a
regular no wonder in America no one's
like so far yes it would give me so much
anxiety or like getting on the phone oh
right there's nothing I love more than a
strongly worded email though now it's
like my emails are so like so business
advice and now my friends are like you
text like you're writing an email like
if I'm asking my friend for a favor I'll
be like hey do you like hobos what my
best friend who I literally like moms do
like earlier text is like see you later
and then
Haidee like hope all is good you know I
just was wanting to know like just
wondering if you were free tomorrow
night
right over the court a podcast with me
like it would mean the world please send
your availability when you're
availabilities and I'll let you know the
details at a later date yes so much
it's like lit and they're like why do
you talk like that and I'm like right
you know what it's easier for me to talk
like that to my friends and then know
how to write an email then to write an
email like I'm hugging my friends I've
that I've liked that we've been doing
this for so long that I've gotten so
many ridiculous emails that were so
unprofessional and I'm just we laugh
about it cuz we don't care but it like
it's it's a reflection I'm like you want
who you are like you know it like if you
just have the ring just right so get our
book it's coming out October it's a
pre-order now one's happy hour I heard
you have some really prestigious
reviewers yes your book Claudia is one
of the quotes on the back of our book or
the frost oh yeah yeah I asked her to do
it and I was very prestigious honor I
she is amazing you're amazing as well
everyone here at the toast is amazing
and I just thought it would make sense
it's like Hello good morning Millennials
like our whole thing is Millennials so
yeah so what's your number one tip for
like young professionals who need career
advice yeah so a lot of young
professionals who are happened to be
Millennials just assume that everything
is just gonna be given to them and just
like everything is just gonna work out
well you have to work really hard and
that's really you have to do some stuff
a lot of stuff you don't want to do and
it takes a long time until you get to do
the stuff that you really love to do and
I think it's also a common misconception
like do what you love well like you
might not be amazing at what you love to
do like that whew should say a hobby so
it should really be about like following
what you're passionate about and that
like it matches your skills you know
skill set and then if honestly
eventually it turns into a work like it
turns into work and you might not love
it right at the end of the day so but
that's why it's work like yeah exactly
you're not supposed I don't think anyone
even people who love their job love it
every minute every minute and but that
but that's reality and I think like
people need to accept reality totally
and ioniq step back like they're just
gonna be so excited to wake up every day
yeah like so work well put like oh I can
just walk in whenever I you know like
it's it's it's work like and it builds
character to like work really hard and
work towards something that isn't about
you and earns yeah yeah for sure for
sure so what's been your favorite thing
about starting up batches and then
what's also been the most challenging
yeah um well my favorite general thing
is the fact that like we get to I get to
go to work with my two of my best
friends like we've like I said known
each other forever so that's really
amazing we can say whatever we want to
each other and like you know nothing
happens um yeah and also just like the
we get to sort of speak our minds and
like we have a platform to do so and I
think that having like young women email
us DM us and say things that like wow
like whatever your this thing that you
said like really changed my way of
thinking or you know just like things
like that like but I think you also said
in like in the toast that like just
changing one person's life a tiny bit
it's really rewarding and so that's
definitely my favorite thing
besides my friends and challenging is
running a company and like I mean we
know none of us like we didn't have any
business background right um
like I was gonna I was pre-med like I
was I wanted to be a reconstructive
plastic surgeon and have all the
children that's so cute could have been
on botched that was a question that for
you what would you be doing yeah if you
weren't right so that's what I went to
school for I graduated I graduated like
fully bio major pre-med but then when I
got to senior year I was like wait like
how many more years of school do I have
to do I can't this isn't this isn't a
thing that's gonna happen right like I
have to go to school for 12 more years
well well if you want to be a
reconstructive plastic surgeon yeah oh
my god there's like there's like the res
there's the med school then the resident
you don't start your career till you're
like 30 want to be your super specialist
yeah and like my parents were always
like you'd be the best you know so you
know
but we don't have this isn't therapy so
but I'll work that yeah but it worked
out and things like we started our
senior year of college and I had
something to do and it wasn't you know I
applied for City Year people don't know
as I did not get in what city here I
don't know you like work but it's got a
medical thing no it was like something
in the in in New York City where you
just like help kids in public schools
but I didn't get it no it's okay it
worked out for the best
totally everything that happens is meant
to be mm-hmm what's your favorite part
of your new podcast died starts tomorrow
yeah I love doing this podcast um it
comes out every every Sunday I started
my own podcast or that's a great day for
it to come out because yeah exactly diet
starts basically Monday or whatever
I love the Walt no - it goes to it I
love the d-ends
I love people emailing and saying like I
didn't know people actually thought this
way like we talk about like things that
people don't really say about like
weight loss in like the struggle with
trying to be well and like how wellness
isn't what it looks like on Instagram
like it's not now you know like sipping
your beautiful tea like no one has
teacups so like you know and so the DMS
that come in and all the emails for
people asking for us for advice I find
that so so rewarding and amazing and
that like also when people email us I am
like oh I'm not alone you know totally
you know so that's amazing and also like
having the opportunity to speak to all
these different guests is really really
cool so like what's something that
you've learned from a guest that like
shook you to the core like that you
didn't realize about dieting and
wellness or more a tip that you might
have others who are generally what I'm
learning is there's no right way to do
anything there's no one way to lose
weight there is no one way to live
forever it's really just what works for
everyone and like the thing that I am
learning is that being on a diet is not
like really good for you because it like
perpetuates being on a diet for a whole
life like we had an email from somebody
who is like she's like I just want to
say like
it's gonna be a really weird email but
I'm 60 years old and I still think the
way that you guys think and it doesn't
like really change I'm like this is both
rewarding and scary right no that's
that's gonna like I've been on a guy at
my life and I don't know how to not
because it there's so minute there's so
much ingrained in us and so like that
that's what I'm really learning and just
trying like up for me like I throw I put
my scale away because of the podcast yes
that I deleted all my calorie counting
apps yeah because it's because you're
its obsessive like oh yeah I'm I have
OCD like it allows me to be good at what
I did like what I'm you know but also it
can hurt you and you like your personal
life so yeah I mean that was huge for me
because then you're sort of I'm like
accountable to myself like I'm not you
know what like you only really want to
write down what you ate is like you ate
well you know what I mean like if I had
like a giant three piece of pizza I'm
like we're gonna ignore the calorie
check my steps when I know I walked off
yes exactly
you only want to weigh yourself when you
feel skinny in the morning right you you
dearly I'm gonna you know I'm so get one
more day yeah exactly
you're also weight doesn't matter it's
like how you feel how you look look how
you feel about how you look right so
that those are big things that I'll have
changed my life personally in my
struggle but yeah I I love doing that
podcast I host it with my co-founder
Sammy and you listen for sure I'm going
to maybe I'll learn something so you act
we had Derek pets on the show last week
and he told us that he's working on
something with you guys yeah you also
have done a collaboration with comments
by celebs yes sick fans over here you do
I heard about them because of I think
Claudia I told ya yeah yeah I posted it
I'm like what is this account click and
then obsessed write work with us no it's
like so necessary know what they're
doing and it's great um so you do really
great like collaborations what qualifies
like some a brand that you would work
with or support yeah I mean I loved
comments by celebs because I just first
of all I personally loved it like I feel
like the three of us and like all of our
team like we're really in
what goes on in the world because we're
the audience and so if we feel strongly
about something that they'll will pursue
and find a way to work with like so
comments by celebs
I found that Instagram was like they
like celebs we're commenting more so
that would feet get featured to look
they would be relevant for something
that isn't whatever their job is they're
getting they're relevant for their
comments which is so interesting that's
like a new like I don't know like a new
level of thirst it's a new it's a new
level of thirst but it's like a new
playing field like now you can be famous
for your comments and then that
oh but like maybe they're comedian like
oh maybe they can get their you know
like yeah there's a good new so Chrissy
Teigen syndrome but she's she's the
first so yeah she's been doing it before
yes she was doing it before there was
comments by so she was just doing it
because it's who she is so yeah so I
mean I really really liked them and we
were like okay they were also kind of
reminded when we met with the girls and
with you guys kind of remind us of
ourselves when we started that's okay
yeah and so they're they're amazing and
yeah so everyone should listen to their
podcast we record in our office and it's
called comments by celebs podcast so
you've had a lot of celebrities in your
office like interviewing and working
with Yahoo is the nicest sub that you've
met through um there have been a lot I
mean I have literally such bad memory
like it's you know like when people ask
you what's your favorite movies I'm like
I can't think of all right right the
most recent one was Kelly Ripa she came
in to record for a comic spy celebs she
was so so nice like just really like a
genuinely chipper human being and like
she was like oh I like want to take
photos of everyone she said my trainer
cancelled like I'm here to stay you know
and she was so nice and was just down to
you know she way I appreciate that she
wasn't like in the air of her own
celebrity she was like really just down
to hang out with us like talk like she
like she asked this question about her
office and like our business and it was
really nice I liked her a lot like I
spire to be someone like that for sure
you know humble and tonight
have to ask who was one of the worst if
we want to just like give clues you know
like like a riddle almost um no one was
like like came in like monster tore
apart like everyone's you know hopes and
dreams but there was one person I won't
even say it's a girl or guy who just was
so full of themselves that I was like
gagging I can't give more reality world
or reality okay that makes it worse
which makes set it almost makes sense
like the super talented people like
aren't so so full of themselves they
could be and it would be fine yeah like
Kelly Ripa was full of herself like I
would understand what makes sense right
but a reality TV person being full of
themselves is right it'll come battle
down to earth
totally or like you know but yeah that
was but a lot of the reality stars that
come to our office which we got a lot
are really nice fun cool a lot I do
everything like Jax is so fun taxes our
face so fun like he's nothing like he
was portrayed on TV always say that like
it's so hard watching him on TV and like
having today disagree with what he's
doing cuz it's terrible but you knowing
that in person he's like a really nice
cool guy and like down-to-earth yeah and
it's also funny to see people who are
exactly like they are on TV so it's like
true reality you know what I mean yeah
like um I guess the Vanderpump like Lala
she's like so she's exactly the same as
she is she was just like cool like just
out there fun
do you see she was hanging out with
Khloe Kardashian I'm sorry
poker I saw and then I saw in some some
Instagram it was like side by side like
her next to the real Khloe and then like
Sheena next to the wax figure yeah I
guess she like just posted a picture
with it was just so so funny because
it's like you know what no Lala out here
hanging out with like the real club I
don't remember which inst I wish I could
like say it no but I saw in the toasters
get that like didn't Sheena post that
picture from the wax museum which is
just like made me sad but it's fine yeah
thank you so much for joining us thank
you as you have so a pleasure
where can everyone follow you follow
betches keep up with the podcast yes at
matches is betches I'm at a lien coop
Paula Casas at diet starts tomorrow we
have so many other podcasts we have you
up which is super popular it's dating
and sex we have so many so just like
follow Bechet as we talk about
everything we do perfect thank you so
much thank you guys we will see you
tomorrow I'll be co-hosting with Darren
Karp we're talking about tonight is the
night Real Housewives of New York boat
episode carta hanging out Claudia's in
Columbia as we speak
who knows if she will be like on the
same boat why she isn't but we'll be
dissecting it all tomorrow so we will
see you then
you